hi I'm Miriam Bukhari a student in the
2016 class of the MIT Sloan MBA program
I'm 26 years old and a millennial what
do young workers Millennials today want
from their jobs and careers and how do
they want to establish and maintain a
balance between work and life these
questions are important to lots of
people employers wanting to recruit and
keep young talented workers Millennials
like me who are about to enter the
workforce and hordes of consultants
giving us and business leaders advice
about the changing workforce so let's
start with what our parents told us when
we were growing up my parents like I
would guess many of your parents if your
millennial said that if I worked hard in
school and got a good education I would
do well in life even better financially
and socially than they did but today
many of us are worried that our
generation the Millennials might not
achieve that goal and if we ask young
people today if that's what they really
want out of their careers we get
different answers for example the people
who took this course last year so that
their top priority was addressing big
important problems at work while also
having a sensible work-life balance
doing well financially was also
important but these data like other
surveys of young professionals show that
it's not at the top of the list hi my
name is Eileen Rivera and I'm a
third-year student at Wellesley College
I'm also a millennial about to enter the
workforce and as you saw there isn't one
single most important aspiration this
extended quote from a young woman in the
class illustrates how she sees these
different aspirations fitting together
my dream includes a job where I do
important work something that gives back
to the community I dream of having a
work-life balance that melds together I
hope that I'm able to utilize technology
to make work more accessible and
eventually have the option to do work
from home I do hope to be able to find a
company that has a retirement plan where
the company contributes some percentage
to the plan in some regards I hope to
have some of the same benefits that my
parents had health insurance retirement
plans etc
most importantly I want to have passion
for my work I want my work to help
people and I hope to make a decent
decent living while making the
generations before me proud all this
suggests that even though our generation
shares many of the same concerns of
prior generations we care more about
having an impact and work-life balance
and money our our generation of workers
also looks very different than
workforces of the past both in America
and around the world
almost half of Americans today are
people of color and many Millennials
here and around the world are children
of immigrants or immigrants themselves
we will all be working together learning
from each other and some of us will be
starting families that blend our diverse
backgrounds so we will want our
workplaces to embrace who we are and
where we come from but many Millennials
are also having a hard time getting
started in the u.s. the majority of
Millennials say we are not earning
enough money to live like we want to one
of more than a third of Millennials
report that we depend on our families
for financial support so many of us have
to start out in debt from student loans
and can't find full-time or career
building jobs in the fields we studied
in school how does all this affect how
and where we work well for one thing we
move around from job to job a lot a
recent survey said people between age 22
and 32 changed jobs between one and four
times in the last five years and 66%
expect to change jobs again in the next
few years many of us are also sending a
clear message that we want more
opportunities not just for ourselves but
for everyone regardless of race or the
income bracket in which they were raised
that's why some are protesting against
low wages at fast food companies racial
injustice and income inequality as seen
by the Occupy Wall Street movement in
2011 and by protests of women and men
who are forced to work in unacceptable
conditions in garment factories in
global supply chains what does this mean
for the next generations of managers of
leaders Sloan School MBAs who study data
from last year's class concluded that as
managers of the future they will need to
listen to their employees engage them in
solving problems that really matter to
the organization and to society and be
flexible and how when and where people
work so they can be
productive and attentive personal and
Family Affairs those are the messages
sent by last year's class let's see how
this year's class can bring our voices
into the process of shaping the future
of work